hello welcome to honest trailer
commentaries for The Lion King the one
that came out this year with blonde I'm
with Dan we're gonna be talking about
the film our behind the scenes thoughts
some cut jokes did make it to the final
cut we will be responding to your fan
questions not great this week guy step
it up and teasing next week's honest
trailer we hope you enjoy this film not
very good well it's great because it's
it's basically the same think that there
are so many good elements and a lot of
them are still here it just doesn't work
it is hard to take my experience with
1994's Lion King and put that to the
side because if this was the first time
I've seen the Lion King you at least
come away like that
Hakuna Matata is a catchy sign that is
what it's flat I would be like why do
people like this movie so much because
everything in this movie except for
Billy Eichner is complete so flat it's
because of the dull dead soul the size
of animal yes it's and I agree animals
may or may not have souls I think they
have soul they do but you can't see it
in their eyes in this movie not
computer-generated uh there's a deadness
behind like I mean we know what an
animal's emotions are like because we've
seen them tail well it's not like your
dogs never happy to see you or sad that
you're leaving or they're hungry or
whatever but we know what those look
like and they're not the same as human
emotions whereas Lion King they're
experiencing human emotions and in a
cartoon you can animate them to look
that way and when you have a real
looking warthog he's just a warthog it
was a technical marvel but it's it's
it's colder than a Stanley Kubrick yeah
it to me it's it's a tech demo that went
on way too long because that opening
shot is incredible and that's what sold
the movie or at least what they'd like
alive is the proof of concept like yes
we can do the Lion King but it's when
you get to yeah the dialogue scenes and
character moments the pathos like you're
just there's a disconnect there you're
just walking it's two hours of animals
just like yeah well the driving and like
talking like an animal talks and that's
just like some games a real problem in
musical numbers because like I just
can't wait to be king I really noticed
they can Simba young Simba in the
original cartoon is basically dancing
while these things that and this one he
literally just kind of prancing it's
really boring would it have been a
better choice to like stretch the
realism and give them like a Cheshire
cat grins at least bring that sort of
interesting animated dynamism to the
photo real look of the movie right could
have been an interesting combination
well yeah like you can you can animate
it in a way that it'll look good to
modern audiences like Zootopia or
something where the characters are still
expressive like animated characters they
don't look photorealistic at all I mean
you sort of find a halfway meeting point
between those but you can't good sounds
like that's something that's screaming
for you to kill me then go all cartoon
might seem like this would be to justify
doing this they had to make it so
different from the cartoon for them to
be able to say this isn't just a cash
grab we're doing this right you know
there's a reason for this to exist and
the reason was it's all photo realness
they couldn't inject any animation or
cartoon enos into it because then it
would then the question of me is like
well then why are you just what do the
cartoon and but it just went so far the
other way that to me it was I was just
more like there's something else you
could do you could add or subtract or
rearrange parts of the story you know
which they did not yeah there are the
Julie Taylor version they just put
people in big theatrical costumes out
there like they do on the Broadway stage
yeah that's like for TV let's watch
Australia for Lion King to k-19 and see
what we have to say about it
Cinderella transformed a passive heroin
into an active hero Jungle Book crafted
a narrative out of scattered source
material the other woods were movies now
Disney's next live-action rehash will
update the original by doing the exact
same thing but somehow 30 minutes longer
and drained of all of its charm whoa how
bleak is that pause I mean there's like
we've had mixed results so far with
Disney live-action like you couldn't
quite some all of them up with the same
brush because I think we all like
Cinderella and Jungle Book maybe not
better than their originals but
certainly there's a reason for them I
like a book better than the original I
do too
I really do yeah I think it's a more
complete movie I think it flows better I
think the sense of peril is there more I
like it more than the animator yeah and
Cinderella well obviously visually it
doesn't exceed the original but like
there's more there's more depth to it
there's more character it kind of added
a lot of comedy into that one kids like
a rom-com the live-action version which
works it's a different energy than the
enemy
well the animated version is really like
mice it's almost - almost completely
different movie yeah
beating the Beast is a staged recreation
yep Lion King is the staged recreation
Dumbo is weird
yeah because that movie was only like 65
minutes and you couldn't use 15 minutes
of it and so they basically just wrote a
whole it was Michael Keaton's wonder
Emporium and also there's a flying
elephant hmm but if I like most of the
world
skip Dumbo yeah and I liked Aladdin but
just barely
yeah it's fine yeah I like I think it
does a better job of balancing it I mean
they've been - it's changed some things
you know it felt like more like its own
movie so they burned through I think all
of their grade a s tear source material
yeah
we get mermaid that's already happening
in Little Mermaid Little Mermaid we
still got a that so it's Grimm Oliver
and company baby there really are things
you could sort of change and improve
they're not it's not like Holy Scripture
anymore yes
so like sword in the stone Black
Cauldron like those could actually be
great try that with Pete's dragon and it
bombed you're right you are not
realistic it's like you go back to
before the 90s Renaissance era and there
are actually our movies that people
don't value so much that it's they're
untouchable you could sort of read will
see my ladies room they will just redo
these same handful of movies over being
like here's a new New Groove from the
Emperor I'd like to see a live-action
Hercules Disney movie but we have too
many Hercules we've got with the Motown
and they'll figure that one out yeah
yeah all right well there's some
interesting projects but as far as like
a grade like franchise stuff then the
other running pretty thin yeah yeah
they're breezing through it pretty quick
hopefully we'll all be gone by then yeah
Pinocchio journey to the savanna deep
inside the heart of a CGI render farm
for a film that brings animals to life
with such uncanny real someone should
have realized early on that this was a
bad choice where her kids musical since
these ultra realistic beasts look dull
when they say
[Music]
that's the doesn't look like the voices
are coming out of the animal no John
Oliver clip I picked that purpose
because it just like no part of my brain
is fooled by this bird sounds like John
Oliver and so I got a fundamental level
it just doesn't is like listening to
people do a reading of The Lion King
over this footage right and I think that
they did like it was kind of cruel to
most of the actors where I feel like
they cast them anthropomorphic like
their voices or what or what we should
be listening for like that's why you
know Yago is Gottfried or to dick or
something it's not because Gilbert
Gottfried look like because you're
making them look like animals yeah I
don't know better than most
yeah like yeah the bird the bird is the
biggest problem yes I could see that you
have a beak I need an English bird man
[Music]
all right keep going so we have symbols
the Aristocats one last time or at least
until execs raised concerns about q3
2029 revenue projections is that what
John's supposed to be saying that it
like fails son I'm like that's not a
word that I guess it isn't like I've
never heard that word in my life those
new words in the internet were yeah I
never heard fail son I mean it's pretty
self-explanatory it's like a failed this
ion like it's here inherited everything
and sucks the heir to a fortune who
doesn't deserve or know what to do with
their I should
act 1 Simba Elsa I'm out of the loop now
Kendall Roy I'm outside I'm outside the
circle of life where do we tell them
what visco girls aren't no guy that's a
hole that's a hole commentary and an
alright pause we were actually time at
this is like what is the king's job or
his duties as the Lion King because it's
like he's not he's more than king of
just the food chain he's an actual
government official well that's how it's
supposed to work
no I'm clear about what the duties of
king other than deciding whether hyenas
can hang out or have to stay away some
kind of weather element involved yeah we
do have one see where Zazu comes to give
the Morning Report and you're like okay
we're gonna hear but it's just animal
puns law and order in the jungle and
chooses which animals he can kill and
which ones you can't kill it's kind of a
caste system where hyenas are at the
bottom oh definitely and that's pretty
much it he doesn't really seem to have
authority over any other animal they all
seem pretty much like self-regulating
like it's that he murders yeah objects
that he chooses to murder and it's
justified because part of the circle
well he also gets you know false
legitimacy from the priesthood monkey
there's some element of art but
otherwise it's your standard
primogeniture Game of Thrones you know
first chosen by God here's my question
do that well we talked about it in the
thing but like the animals talk we know
they don't we don't always see them talk
but like when when
and let's say Simba or or his father are
killing an antelope is they I mean now
is moments away from killing they kind
of kind of gloss over it later she's
gonna even remember like that would be
pretty traumatized by the end of also
female lines do all of the hunting yeah
men just kind of chill they hang well
they've got a lot of meetings a lot of
hearings let's get this all lion rip his
dinners guts that was so much more than
celebrities doing a table read of the
Lion King while a nature dot plays on
mute in the background they also get to
do some white dick like James Earl Jones
so for a guy who's almost 90 sounds like
a guy who's almost 80 everything the
light touches Mary James
they probably stayed in the final cut
because every adult is asleep by the
time he shows up circle know it's a line
yeah it's a meaningless line of
indifference and beyonce knowles
carter's many glorious beyond systems
whether it's one of her motivational
beyond sayings you are our queen you
have to take your place
turn tire roll yeah motivational poster
she's like to hang in there cat are you
with me lions
or some of our inspirational beyond
singing song in there running about
Beyonce combined with some white work
play they have not I repeat not jokes at
our expense I tell you my family safety
and I'm saying this at my own free will
Lucchese are here don't have any jokes
about Beyonce they like to share with
the publishing I think suspend a
national treasure yep alright for
another massive Disney cell phone in
that all they do is make massive amounts
of money off things they already own
that started with a near-perfect film
but grab critical failure out of the
jaws of success like why would you turn
be prepared in a spoken word the need
for a different dream he can see
anyways yeah after 1994 for another spin
on the Hollywood circle of life we're an
original story is born Disney adapts it
makes it into an animated classic craps
out some corrective video sequels so
pause we got some we got some we got I
love that cut to be doing this we got we
took some heat on it previously but
people don't like it when we say that
blinds to cinemas pride is a crapped-out
prelates a standby that one they do they
attack of the clones of The Lion King
franchises yeah I think you were just 12
when you saw it
I'll be honest I don't really remember
it I know I've seen it but I couldn't
tell you what happens in Simba's pride
unfairly comparing them to the Aladdin
direct to VHS claims now you can return
to the Jafar people angry I think that
one holds up better than most Disney's
he fades to black every 20 minutes
because they're the state of modern
cinema pause I am NOT a butthurt critics
well this is from Disney's perspective
oh yeah yeah I probably was being Bob
Iger probably thinks you yeah but her
critics like Coppola yeah you know like
the Titans the cinema no we call them
[ __ ] put up black panther up against
anything they ever made yeah you can try
I liked black panther but well anything
they've ever made so it can pick black
bears I got the best of what they've
done the best of what they so he's like
output gods on same things
versus black pants or insane I just
going black no that's objectively crazy
bonafide Wow yeah yeah Wow agar okay
well thanks okay keep going
you should talk about the poo I mean
yeah so we're so aggressively part of
the film we have to show how the main
gets to Rafiki yeah no you don't if you
didn't have the entire circle of life
number to express to us that that was
the theme of the movie yeah this scene
could do it like oh it's all kind of
connected I get like the fur goes from
him and then they're gonna use it in the
nest and it's eaten by this animal that
goes but we already had the search like
that's been communicated where's the
matically this movie doesn't really seem
to be about a circle of life at all it
seems to be about you know pride and
clawing your way to the top of family
government after you've been exiled like
this you know if this were magnolia
something maybe you have a circle of
life it's courage I would say is what
this the digestive tract on the river
its sequences that makes this version
longer yeah and yet they cut out the the
my favorite joke in the movie which is
when the Rafiki hits them in the head
with the staff it's like what'd you do
that for is like it doesn't matter it's
in the past that's a funny joke yeah
give it everything in there yeah you
they kept they added poop they cut be
prepared in half and made it spoken word
and they cut up the funniest joke in the
movie yeah I hope that was Jon Favreau's
like first note day one city dad like I
got this idea for poop it's unrealistic
that Rafiki would hit him in the head
impossible okay keep going let's finish
up story was pretty cutie
all the other ones look identical to
each other I can't I'm Forrest Forrest
now I'll be a monkey and also an uncle
avoiding rumors of Timon and Pumbaa
being a gay couple by giving one of them
a kid yes weird now Geographic presents
Beyonce's Lion King this movie is a huge
problem telling day and night apart
[Music]
watching the study that's the most
egregious yeah because it's present
tense and also has the same problem that
I don't remember that I've watched it it
seemed like it was a little tonight
happens at night I thought it did huh
will confirm will confirm that but it
just it's so weird because they're
talking they're speaking in present
tense yes and it's like not it's not
easy
oh we're gonna go do this later tonight
like and it's not like like it's your
animating it anyway since we can't shoot
this sequence at night it won't look
good it's like position your fake light
you know shame and scars in this day
today for fake night is love tonight
somewhere alright let's see some deleted
scenes hopefully just as classy as that
like James Earl Jones's signature
gravitas which is aged like a fine wine
left on the kitchen counter for 20 years
that's when Harley that's the one story
okay you spray bottles to separate cats
and heaters all right let's discuss some
fan questions and again I'd like to
reiterate step it up come on that's a
better quarry to ride most of them were
why aren't you funny but phrase in the
form of think you're saying in subby bus
okay right right
rephrase your insults in the form of
herb cause whale right is there even any
point in doing an honest trailer for it
since it's just the same movie but in
live-action this is related to several
other questions edges did we consider
just reusing the script from the
animated one maybe I think I was
spitballing of like we do one section of
that and then really and you probably
didn't even notice we did the exact same
thing last time but but we did that in
Beauty and the Beast we did that okay
there you go
no we don't want to redo the songs
it's it's it is different because even
though the material is the same it works
so great in the original one and then
not at all here so like you kind of want
to comment on that Gulf all the
celebrities are different obviously the
animation style yeah why would make the
medium bucks it's like you get new stuff
every week we're not you guys are making
medium medium
Grande dollars yes medium can afford a
Grande it's a life-size cutout of
Slipknot it is life-size anyways Kakashi
writes how the hell did this movie make
1.5 billion dollars
damn you chard quickly quickly
very quickly aggressively and people
know the name I don't know if viewing
the Beast made a billion dollars to I
people like kids are annoying and people
like to put them in a movie theater be
quiet for two days that they know it's
gonna be okay yeah that's gonna happen I
have the lion race there just Derby know
yeah I agree the fighting stuff at the
end not troubling at all in the original
version a little weird here yeah cute
they were born hyenas they were like
they were like gazelles that turned bad
and now they're getting what they
deserve
the circle of life they like right come
clean up after you kill the cartoon
they're like skulking around they look
kind of swarthy like they're just like
these are spotted hyenas and those are
scavengers so they wouldn't be killing
prey anyway they were beasts cleaning up
after the lions are done yeah not
according to this movie mm-hmm according
to you know biologists movie is anti
anti labor collar
they're just hard-working janitors of
the the Savannah cause it's like
three other species it's like well this
hornbill is annoying but presumably if
we've met another hornbill just like
people like maybe that one would be
fun-loving and laid-back like the Lions
but there's kind of hyenas are bad
they're the only species where there's
no like I mean Eric Andre seemed like
you know he he was worth yeah
individuals all right final question do
you think the Mulan remake next year
will also clear a billion dollars like
all these other ones did on one hand
those are all musicals which is one
element to their mass appeal I Milan
isn't I mean on the other hand it's
pretty well known more popular with
younger audiences and something like
Dumbo what do you think speculate it's
got a lot I'm eeen I love I love I'm
gonna make a man out of you that's a
great song but I can also see why
they're not gonna do it I don't know I
think it's got a lot of potential I
thought I didn't mind the Jungle Book
for example it was mostly not a musical
they paid lip-service owns maybe from
the I mean there's a whole lot of issues
with that with Disney and China and
everything else and move on but I think
it has the potential yes if it's a great
movie in which I think it else has the
potential to be I think he's got a shot
okay yeah I think it's it's riskier it's
gonna feel more different from the
original movie
I don't think Mulan well-beloved I don't
think it's as iconic and remembered as
Lion King and this is like a it's gonna
be a war movie like it's gonna be a
little more serious I think that has
some advantages older audiences might
have more appeal if it looks like it's
epic and action-oriented but I don't
know if it's gonna feel like as safe a
bet for fan is the loved of our people
our age you have the most money
supposedly to spend you know so I think
that you could tap into the potentially
the Marvel crowd more so than even young
young kids but I think he want the young
young kids cuz that's who sees it over
and over again who you brand the parents
ticket and the kids ticket and like I
agree like this is it seems like a more
serious movie which I think I'll have it
be making less money because it's a
historical epic it's not fun kids fairy
tale I mean you do have all the other
stuff that goes
maybe it's great and different enough
it'll be buzzy and that way like I do
think it has breakout potential but yeah
I don't know if it's quite as safe of
like Grand Slam bets something like Lyon
kids know like Lion King was all but
guaranteed yeah like you still had in
Lion King I don't think it's also
coincidence that they crossed a billion
and they were the most slavish li
faithful in some ways as far as like all
the songs are intact etc yeah well not
Lion King like butchered be prepared be
prepared but they had to make room for
beyond singing and montage well there
you go that's Lion King 2019 if we seem
unenthused it's cuz we just had to watch
The Lion King 2019 several times but
hopefully next week won't be as as dour
because it's gonna be a lot more
exciting lots more excitement lots more
action mm-hmm lots more testosterone
just spitballing for what next week saw
his trailer dosterone fueled yeah yeah
Emily so there you go we hope you'll
join us same time same place
comte's bye bye
[Music]